Hello everyone, this is Frank Defratis, and welcome to HoloTalk, the internet's laser and holography talk show enjoyed in over 42 countries throughout the world.
And now, here's this week's show.
Len, it's Frank Defratis.
Oh my god, I missed your voice, Frank.
I forgive me.
That's okay.
How are you?
I'm doing great.
Fine, you know.
For an older fine.
It's really good.
You know, Frank, I uh whenever I miss you, I go to your website and I read all kinds of incredible stuff.
I mean I mean, you're so brilliant.
You really are, Frank.
All right.
We can stop that now.
No, I'm serious.
I I uh I really do that.
It's comforting because uh I the other day I was thinking about laser diode uh lasers.
Um and uh you your stuff is still still out you're still doing holograms, right?
Oh, absolutely.
Yeah, I have someone coming in tomorrow, coming up from Florida for a workshop.
They're visiting well relatives in Philadelphia, so they're gonna drive up to uh Allentown for a workshop tomorrow.
Did you ever consider um these are some of the questions I had in my head?
Did you ever consider um um using a Palmer plate?
I don't know if you can buy the resin from DuPont, whether they sell it to the public or they just keep it in house.
No, I I wouldn't have the power or the uh wavelength right now to do that, I don't believe.
I do have an argon laser here now.
Oh, you do?
Yeah.
Wow.
Did you build it or make it?
I got it from someone else, and uh I still have to get it hooked up because it needs the uh two twenty triple phase and like two and a half gallons of water a minute.
Oh my god.
So I don't want to I don't want to knock the neighborhood out, you know.
It's a power failure in the wintertime and it's not snow, it's Frank Defriz.
Hey, listen, I miss making holograms so much.
But um the only thing that's kept me going, especially when I got some of my sight back.
I saw you after I got my sight back, didn't I?
It's been a couple years.
It might have been two thousand and one, two thousand and two, but that's a long time.
Right, and j it it's just appropriate that you call now because all of a sudden I realize there's something wrong with my sight.
You know the lens implants that they put in?
Yeah.
Well, the one I'm using, the lens implant seems to have torn loose in internally, and they're gonna have to take it out and put another one in.
I'm going in for surgery on the second of November.
Oh, I hope everything works out all right.
'Cause in an implant when it after it's uncurled, it's got springs on it to hold it in place.
So hey, it's one thing to have an opp one operation, but this is two that first you gotta demolish the building and then put another one up, so it's the anesthesia, I guess I should be worried about, you know, as you get older.
How old are you now?
I'm seventy-two, Frank.
No kidding.
Why don't you tell the listeners how you got started with holography?
That was way back in the sixties, wasn't it?
Uh yeah, I didn't you travel up to Canada or something?
Yeah, well what happened, I had read about uh I r I r I I read somewhere first of all, I read details about holography in the current magazines like Scientific American things.
Um photography by laser, I think there was a big article.
But when I realized that the uh sixty seven Expo advertised that they had a hologram on display.
Or several holograms, I just decided to go.
I think it was um earlier late September 'cause it was cold on the road, and I just drove straight to Canada from work.
I left work one day, walked out of school, got in the car, and long ride up to uh uh let me see, it was uh held in uh was it Montreal?
Yeah.
At some point I was doing ninety miles an hour on this open highway that had opened up.
But when I got there I found out that the um everything was on strike, all the public transportation.
And it was cold.
I mean it really wasn't what I expected, but um I went late at night and I ran over to the booth where uh the map said the hologram was, and the lights were out.
No.
And I couldn't see anything, there's nothing to see.
Because the hologram was on display like an outdoor kiosk.
Yeah.
It wasn't like you were an indoor building, but I still had a great time.
I had my three D camera with me and uh after many, many hours I even went through the uh you know, there are a lot of mythical things.
I went through the labyrinth and I saw the minotaur.
Matter of fact, I took three D pictures of him because I carried a tripod, the sculpture.
Oh, okay.
And I was doing time exposures.
You know, I'm talking about minutes and counting and covering it with a hat I bought because I didn't want to touch the camera lens, came out razor sharp in three D.
And um Well you did a lot of three D work, didn't you with the photography too?
You know, recently in the last few years, I was able to buy a scanner, and one of the reasons I won my my computer is really down.
Um the Dell seems to have died.
I don't hear the hard drive running.
I need a new computer.
Yeah.
But one of the reasons that uh I wanted that, I figured if I could put the um both sides, both stereo images, in the computer, I could reformat that them as an ana glyph, and I I did.
I started experimenting with that.
Okay.
And that way just anybody with a red and blue pair of uh paper glasses could see the things I had done in 3D, including my grandkids.
Oh, and you were gonna put them on a web page, I guess, right?
Yeah, yeah.
Do you have that web page finished?
No.
You know what?
All of us didn't get on the computer's busted, the scanner's sitting here.
Uh the printer doesn't work.
I need one of everything, but you know what?
In the last few years I have been in and out of the hospital.
It's crazy.
And now with this uh vision thing, which is the last thing I envisioned.
I'm just struggling to stay uh, you know, stay afloat, Frank.
Um because i it's hard without help.
You know, living alone, you you've always lived with somebody.
Yeah.
And you're surrounded by I guess some friends or family.
It's really hard when you uh I'm surround I'm surrounded by my own multiple personalities.
No, no, you're a resourceful dude.
I re I remember you pulling up on your motorcycle.
Yeah.
I remember you coming down for uh my mother's uh funeral.
I mean, you always get around where you want to get, Frank.
I I really, you're fabulous.
How old are you now, Frank?
Me.
I just turned fifty.
Oh my god.
You're just a baby cake.
Just a baby cake.
Hold on a second.
That's the uh that's the weather alert.
Were they gonna tell you sunshine's coming out?
Yes, the sun's coming out.
I miss being in the basement of the Franklin Institute.
Yeah, why don't you tell listeners about your involvement with the Franklin Institute and uh Central High School, too.
Well, I had gone to Central as a as a young kid and wasn't doing well, and I transferred out and eventually graduated from Northeast, so it was strange to get back to Central, but um and I'll show you what age does for you.
What was the original question?
That's all right.
All right, I was reading I was reading an article.
Yeah, I was reading an article, I think it was in the uh the inquiry, and uh they pointed out that the Franklin Institute had gotten a uh grant and they were gonna they were gonna offer holography classes, blah, blah, blah.
And what what year was this?
I'm guessing it was b it had to be between um it had to be 76, 77.
Somewhere in there.
And so I called up and I I think I spoke to uh Dan Goldwater, who was the head of the science uh curriculum office down there, he was very nice.
And uh Charles Pennerman, who was a minister, he was also involved.
And they told me that there were workshops, and uh I don't remember Scott's last name.
Do you remember Nimsau?
Yeah.
And I realized how eventually I realized that in getting to know him, he was a very nice fellow, Scott.
Uh in getting to know Scott Nemzov, I realized his father was a big shot, a vice president of a um major corporation.
Yeah, Borden Foods, I think.
Exactly.
And it was through um Scott's father that the uh grant money was uh, you know, parceled out, and that's why Scott had a uh place to go.
I think Scott went to Brown University originally.
Yeah, he worked with Harry Casden Silver up there, I believe.
Oh, yeah, okay.
Okay.
And he was very nice, he was kind of protective.
You know, it's uh if you're a major if if you have a craft, uh, you kind of want to protect it, like the original labor unions.
Because if everybody can do it, you lose your uh you lose your speciality.
And I realized that too, because at the time that I discovered the uh holography workshops, I was helping start up the gifted program in the city of Philadelphia in all the public schools.
Mm-hmm.
So I was fascinated.
I couldn't wait when they called me and told me that I could uh participate in the program.
I used to rush down there, and Scott used to do little demos and show you how to make a uh hologram.
But basically by volunteering to spend time in the lab, you really learned uh by trial and error how to how to make a hologram.
Well, that was a pretty good lab down there too, wasn't it?
It was uh it was marvelous because it had a um I think it was a nine by twelve, yeah, it had to be a nine by twelve isolation table that came from what's that big company, uh Newport.
Newport.
In California, and most of the equipment on the table, there was a large laser.
It wasn't a new one, but uh Penneman had rebuilt it if I remember.
I think it was fifty milliwatts.
Yeah, it was at uh Spectra Physics 125.
Right.
Um the special room was set aside, you could lose your hologram in a minute because people would run up and down the stairwell next to the uh next to lab.
But I love being in there, and eventually I figured out pretty much on my own how to make a transmission hologram, and that became I mean, I used to leave work, which is school on a Friday, and you could book a uh I think think of three or four hour um amount of time in the lab where you could work.
And the other people could book, so you know you had to move along.
But I became friendly, believe it or not, because the institute closed up at five o'clock, there was a guard, and they used to hire guards from a service.
And I became very friendly with this one guard, and he would just let me in and he'd let me wait or sit or whatever.
I used to live in the lab all weekend because n very few people the novelty wore off and very few people uh really took advantage of all the time you could spend in the lab.
But I found it uh I found it fascinating.
And the the first time that I made a a magical and high quality four by five hologram, it was just I mean, I was dancing and there was nobody to watch.
Uh it was just it was superb.
So sometimes I used to be in there all weekend because I'd wait if nobody showed up.
The guard, I remember his first name was Henry.
He was he was marvelous, and uh instead of going home I would stay.
Eventually I even used to date out of the Franklin Institute.
Because I had other interests besides and I found out he would let the other person in, and it's strange to be in a building all by yourself.
It was just Henry and myself in the whole institute.
So you are you saying you would take your date to the Franklin Institute of Holographic.
Yeah, she'd come to the door and Henry would say he's down in the lab and he called down and I say it's okay you can let her down.
And uh and I can I can prove it.
One of the women is still alive.
We used to take pa there was a photo booth there.
You know Polaroid photo booth when they first became popular.
You put a dollar in and you take photos.
But it it it it it was superb and eventually out of all this chaos the gifted program was going nowhere and uh one day when they had a show and uh I was the science person in the gifted program I had an idea that I could take some of the money that was being unused when they cl they were going to close up the lab.
And Charles Pennerman helped me write a letter and we rented we we paid Newport to keep the lab open.
And I put out a notice in the in all the Philadelphia schools that anybody that was interested in coming to the lab they'd have to come on their own.
I couldn't provide transportation.
That was the big rub.
People were afraid to send their kids in center city.
Oh I see by themselves.
You know, they're only kids.
Yeah.
But eventually they started coming and we had a lab and we the kids made holograms and it was never it never received any recognition like they did up in Boston or anywhere else.
Because Philadelphia's a strange town.
Uh they knew I was doing holograms.
Yeah.
Uh and some of the parents were wonderful.
Uh one of the parents of a girl, she was she was a brilliant mathematician.
Um she while she was in high school and I was at girls, we were sending her to Penn uh for advanced math.
And uh she used to explain some of the math that I couldn't understand.
But she had to leave the program because one of the teachers told her mother she can go blind working in a lab with lasers.
Oh no unbeliev you know y you run into unbelievable problems.
But her dad was the one he was a lawyer.
He wrote he wrote the uh release that I sent out to all the kids that their parents agreed that they could come to the lab and I was very careful to make sure no one ever got hurt.
You know, it was really safety being a teacher and watching kids was uh was good training because I I had maybe ten, fifteen kids in the lab with which is a lot first of all you don't want any body movement that was the hardest part uh one interesting thing happened Scott Nemzov was going to take off on vacation one summer and he was teaching a class of adults and there was nobody to teach it and I said to Charlie Pennerman I would be glad to teach it if you allow me.
Um I don't have his expertise and I ended up teaching that class and one of the members of the uh board of directors of the uh Franklin Institute was in that class or two of them.
So that was a big thrill being able to make holograms and working with adults.
It was just a marvelous time I mean some people want to go to Paris and some people want to go to Russia.
I just wanted to get to the lab and and work on that uh isolation table.
It was fabulous.
Yeah, they they they were years before I got involved.
I I saw my first show down at the Walnut Street Theater in seventy six.
And I still have the flyer from that show.
Do you have that?
Yeah, I had a poster and I have no idea what I did with the poster.
I'm pretty sure I have that flyer.
Um what about was um Ken Dunkley and um Doug Miller involved with that at all?
Yeah, Doug Miller came on later.
Um I think he he entered one of the workshops 'cause they c they ran different workshops depending on the funding they got.
Uh Ken Dunkley had already been a holographer.
He um he was tied in with the Franklin Institute.
I still remember that.
Remember that face he did with the sand?
Oh yeah, it's classic.
That's a classic hologram.
And uh he would give lectures to uh the rest of us about that.
I mean he he was brilliant.
And I remember the tricolor holograms when they first started showing them when they were swelling things with triethanolamine.
Oh yeah, I love doing that.
Uh oh, you you became an expert at that.
Well, I wouldn't say an expert, but I enjoyed doing it.
Oh, absolutely.
If you wanna if you want a toxicity, just see Frank, he'll supply it.
Yeah, I'm I'm very lucky with all the chemicals 'cause we all, you know, we all get sloppy.
We have our hands in all the chemistry.
Oh yeah.
Um as a kid, my father was a watchmaker and he sent me to cleaning clocks.
I was immersed in benzene, which is a carcinogenic hydrocarbon by today's standards.
I I I'm just amazed that uh I'm still here.
Well, in the early days I used the McCure chloride bleach and the parabenzoquinone and even the bromine.
Oh, well that's violent.
Which violent.
Uh had to clear the house out one time with it.
I once I once remember in college where we we used to manufacture bromine in the chem lab.
And it was in the summertime and we were cooling the condensate with uh uh test tubes to pack the nice and one of the test tubes fell and and broke and there was uh it was pr it was brutal we had eye injuries and everything else.
So you know these things that we work with are pretty pretty pretty toxic.
Yeah that's gotten a little bit better.
But uh I I really never had a chance to finish in the labs.
You know they closed the labs down and I kept I kept working, you know I kept teaching holography as you remember at the uh Franklin Institute as a small workshop and uh even at Widener C college but when plates became and I built the table here in the living room but as plates became difficult and my vision deteriorated became uh you know less accessible.
Yeah.
And it slowly faded away.
And I had a wonderful I used to interview the kids in the gifted program.
Um most teachers would ask them, you know their backgrounds I would ask what's your father do what your grandfather do and they got to know it.
I could hear the kids mumbling in the background.
They would say listen to what he's gonna ask them.
I was looking for a machinist and I found one.
Oh okay.
And he helped me he helped me formulate all those parts that you saw how to scrap metals.
Do you still have those?
I still have those and that's why I was thinking of building a laser diode.
And uh and 'cause I still have a laser.
I think it'll fire up, or I would uh buy him uh a diode laser and supervise him because you know, I I that's how much I love the the holograms.
Well, I'll tell you what, next time I'm down in Philadelphia, I'll stop by and I'll bring one of the shoebox holography books, a box of plates and and one of the small laser pointers for him to work with.
Oh, that's fabulous, Frank.
I'll bring it down.
I know where you're at.
You're still at I won't give the street address, but the number's still seven two seven, right?
Yes, yes.
Yeah.
You're not gonna broadcast this silly conversation, are you?
Oh, yeah, I'm gonna edit it down a little bit.
It has nothing of value in this grave.
Well, it's got some history to it.
I mean, a lot of the people that'll be listening to this show, uh many of them weren't even born when uh you're talking about some of the things that you didn't remember I would spend hours with a pencil and a piece of paper just trying to draw what scientific instruments and plate holders and uh and and pointers and so forth uh, you know, the uh remember we used to move the pinholes, the XY axis.
Oh yeah.
So that if I could get a hold of uh Clarence and he had time in his shop, he would take scraps of metal and work with them and then bring me what he had made and said, Will this work?
And we said, Well, let's rework it this way.
And that's where all the equipment came from that you saw eventually.
Yeah.
I was I was really very fascinated that he would help me do that.
And at Central High School, I finally was able to clean out a roach infested room.
It took me months.
I mean, uh it's a horrible experience to think about, and I'm not kidding about the roaches.
Oh goodness.
And as soon as I got it cleaned out and was able to start building a table in there because I wanted to do holography with the kids, they confiscated it for music storage instruments for the band.
Okay.
So holography never got going at Central.
Isn't that something?
Well, that's because you know, the the administration didn't think it would have any value.
Yeah.
And it was probably oh, I don't know.
I you know, uh a lot of it's politics and and funding and things of that nature.
Well, I I they I didn't ask them for anything.
See, I was supplying all the funding and all the equipment.
Okay.
All I needed was a physical space in the basement.
But it probably wasn't making them any money.
They probably found some way of having the band.
Well, I wasn't a favorite on the list.
Yeah.
And the band Yeah, well, that's the politics part.
Yeah, the you know, a lot depends.
You know, the other principal I was at a school, remember I said all the junior high school kids came from all over the city?
Yeah.
That principal let me not come in that day but report to the Franklin Institute, said I was in his bell, you know, I'd call in that I'm in the building.
And Charles Pennerman, uh and Dan Dan Goldwater, they were they were barbers.
They used to wonder why aren't you here teaching science?
Because the other teachers would bring classes in and they do little trivial experiments like batteries and bulbs, things the teachers could do in their classrooms.
But education hasn't changed much.
I keep think I keep hearing about how things are going to get better in education.
They're probably worse than when I started, because it first of all, it takes it takes a family to bring a kid to school and say, sit here and learn.
And I used to end up screaming at my kids because it didn't matter after many years of teaching, whether I gave a test on any given day.
I would give any kid any test he wanted, any day he wanted.
That's a system nobody uses because it's impossible.
It takes forever and it then I had retests.
You could take if if learning the materials important just let the kid learn in his own time.
Yeah.
And I remember screaming do you want to work at a Burger King or do you want to own one?
Frank Do you have a call coming in?
Yeah hold on a second.
Just one second.
All right well say goodbye to the listeners.
Listen I I'm I'm very honored to be able to speak to any as to my old friend Frank.
All right.
I really mean that.
That's it's been a a terrific treat and uh Frank I'm looking forward to seeing you and talking about lots of things.
Listen Frank when you come down could you bring one of your three dimensional uh portrait holograms a little mini portrait.
Yeah I'll bring it down.
I would love to see one while I can.
All right.
Thanks Frank.
All right I'll talk to you soon.
What a treat talking to you.
Thanks Frank.
All right bye.
Bye bye.